[Applause]
yeah that song still hits jackie now
listen
are you a larger than life backstreet
boys fan or
are you an n sinker i gotta say that i
am a backstreet boy fan
i love them you know i ended up meeting
brian
here at a restaurant if i could just
tell my 12 year old
stuff that i would be having a
conversation but hands down backstreet
boyfriend
all right i'm going to give you those
backstreet boys but i wasn't in sinker
really yes okay we can boy band together
because it was the best of both worlds
as members of the classic boy bands
teamed up for the first time
and only our cassie delora got to sit
down with them
[Music]
[Applause]
yep it's a boy band dream come true nick
aj
joey and lance got together for a good
cause raising a million dollars hosting
bingo under the stars
in celebration of pride month at the
grove in l.a all
right before father's day nick gave us
an update on two-month-old daughter
pearl
who had breathing complications at birth
she's doing
uh really much better we had like a
little rough patch at the beginning um
but
thankfully everything's doing really
good and i'm just i'm just happy now
uh my i got a litter
lance i have to say congratulations
you're expecting me to win
what are you looking forward to most
about becoming a father i mean it's been
a long time coming we've been working on
it for a while so
the fact that we are now five months old
yes
he's right there he's really showing now
he's really sick
he's been the best
my oldest is a she obviously first a
diehard backstreet boy fan
she's converted a little bit lately and
is uh
choreographing and rocking out to these
guys
all so much although i knew all the
lyrics i wanted that way and i was like
where did you hear that
you didn't play it in the house i don't
know exactly
no badging boys well no real rivalries
here
in fact the guys recreated the iconic
pivot scene from friends
shut up just shut up they even have a
group text going
and say future collabs are being talked
about as for any bad blood in the past
never feeling no attention or so look
you know back then there was no social
media there's none of that stuff so
the press and media then pitted us
against each other but no i mean i've
known joey for the longest time
we lived damn down the street from each
other we used to hang out
went to this guy's wedding we have game
night some of my guys in my group didn't
even come to my 40th
he did yeah